she just won't go away
almost a year and a half since losing
the election Hillary Clinton is still
complaining during a speech at Rutgers
University yesterday the failed
Democratic nominee continued to gripe
about getting trounced by Trump was
pretty traumatic because of what had
been expected to happen in the election
which obviously did not and then a lot
of angst and second guessing and
finger-pointing Clinton also hit back at
critics who told her to shut up by
crying sexism I was really struck by how
people said that to me you know mostly
people in the press for whatever reason
like oh you know go away go away they
never said that to any man who was not
elected Al Gore didn't stop talking
about climate change and for heaven's
sakes Mitt Romney is running for the
Senate but I am really committed to
speaking out and doing what I can to
have a voice in the debate about where
our country is going Kimberly I notice
you're sighing deeply inhale exhale
thing it didn't work because I don't
know what it is
I just find her very aggravating because
nobody likes a sore loser man or woman
doesn't matter I'm just talking about a
candidate you ran you did I guess what
you thought was your best you came up
short but nevertheless now she's
actually having to push back against her
own party who's frustrated by her
rhetoric and by the things that she said
that if has to like disavow and step
away from her as well so but I'm not
saying that she should just go away and
never like talk again let her do
whatever she wants but I don't know
necessarily that it's one helping her
case and to foreshores than helping the
Democratic Party she like you said
points out that it's not just people in
the press that are saying shut up it's
Democrats right it's not just like
though it's not just here at Fox News
right like lead with it all the time
because you're definitely people gonna
pay attention but it was Claire
McCaskill who is a Democrat from
Missouri she's a senator two-term
senator she
running for another term in a very tough
race Missouri the president Trump won it
by double digits and so she knows that
she's got to figure out a way to appeal
to voters that Hillary Clinton called
deplorable and it was just a couple of
weeks ago that Hillary Clinton reminded
everybody about the deplorable comment
and basically doubled down on it and she
mentions Al Gore for example if anyone
had a reason to be a sore loser hmm it
would be Al Gore up but and he did stay
in the public eye but not about the
recount he chose an issue and it was
climate change and we made fun of him
mercilessly for it but he wasn't
basically trying to relitigate the 2000
election it was very gracious and he
moved on and that actually helped the
country to be able to move on into unite
after 9/11 and from what I remember it
seemed to me he took almost a year maybe
year and a half off before reemerging
with the beard and talking about the
climate and talking about the Iraq war
so he did lay low unlike mrs. Clinton
Gregg yeah none of her examples hold
water MIT actually did go away and Al
Gore's pet cause was not himself her pet
cause right now is herself and if you
look at John McCain he went back to work
as well I disagree though strongly with
Kimberly I think that Hillary is an
American Hero
I love her she is like the political
version of Jason from Friday the 13th
yeah she is so she just keeps coming
back if only she had this kind of
resiliency in energy oh during the
actual campaign she would be president
but I you know one wild me on this and
he's right I don't want her to go away I
want her to keep coming because the more
she's around the worse it looks for the
Democrat care to respond one I think
that's what's going on here today guys
are having quite a party having a pity
party like she is no but it's not you
know what it is is it's like you're
trying to beat into the so-called dead
horse in this game
guess what you know what I hate to break
it to you but she didn't win she's not
the president she's not so she's out
there Karina and it's a traumatic
experience not only for Hillary Clinton
but for the entire country but I think
you guys loved her as the boogeyman and
if it's not Hillary person she was asked
a very interesting question which by the
way did you notice she only took like
$25,000 for the speech you guys paid
less and Snooki did to go to Rutgers oh
that hurts but you know she was asked a
very interesting question about what she
would do about powerful forces that are
affecting the Republican Party and she
said you know the Republican Party is
coming undone right now because if you
don't run to the far right you can't be
a moderate or you will be bill if the
only thing I would say to that it's hard
to come undone when you have the House
the Senate and the White House and a
majority of the state the high number I
think it's 23 Republicans in Congress
are retiring getting out and it's as the
highest number since 1973 and what
happened in 73 Jesse Watergate Richard
Nixon okay so a lot of people are
pushing away from the heart of the
Republican bill occular Watergate for
the Democrats because we've now had a
Inspector General and a federal
prosecutor begin looking into the FA's
abuses but that's another story for
another time listen to Hillary write on
Monday let's also listen to Hillary talk
about the world under President Trump
right now I'm more worried about whether
our Constitution is going to be honored
whether we will see the rule of law
protected whether we will have the
predictability and stability that we
need in foreign affairs you know as a
former Secretary of State I am deeply
worried about the loss of leadership and
leverage that the United States is
currently experiencing it's funny to
hear Hillary talk about risk
affecting the rule of law
cooking generally I won't mind I'll find
a way to escape so I love this because
she's like I'm concerned about the
Constitution so am i and the people that
are trying to tear down the Second
Amendment doing gun grabs in this
country not even looking at the full
picture in spectrum of what we need to
in terms of making schools and other
places that are soft targets safe for
our children etc whether it's a movie
theater whether it's Paris the Baltic
lon etc so besides that and also she's
concerned about the rule of law so am i
why is there this lawlessness going on
in California sanctuary cities total
disregard for federal law but yet they
still want the money but they're not in
compliance because they want to make
their own laws instead of following
those that are on the books so it's
interesting because President Trump is
the one who's actually showing that he
is looking out for the Constitution to
support it and is making sure that
federal law is enforced and as it
relates to foreign policy so sorry
Hillary we're way better off than when
you and President Obama were in charge
because now we don't have feckless
foreign policy we have effective foreign
policy take a look at Russia take a look
at North Korea
things are getting cleaned up and no
thanks to the mess y'all made I agree
with the lady over there
Kimberly brings up a very good point
about the Second Amendment and if
President Trump said that he was
concerned about how does a party in
power get its voters juiced up to get
off the sofa he may not have to as long
as the left in the media and John Paul
Jones hand a legitimate lifeline and
Juan mentioned this before this
legitimate life light-being we're taking
away your guns
I don't think Donald Trump has to work
too hard to get people off the sofa
because that is the issue I think for
Republicans that could get people like
it you're not taking away my guns the
other thing though is when you listen to
her talk about you know the the
accusation of sexism it is time for a
heroic Democrat to rise from the ashes
and lead some kind of identity
Reformation in which disparities are
looked at logically and not emotionally
and we in a their party offers a healthy
perspective
and not a divisive one and I think
that's gonna I really do think that
that's gonna happen in 2020 that they
were gonna abandon this and there's
gonna be somebody there that gets it I
kind of know who it is the guns thing
that you were talking about because here
you have a situation where the former
Supreme Court justice Stevens says you
know I think that you should repeal the
Second Amendment so the right wing jumps
on is oh whoa look they're trying to
take away our guns because it's easy
button to push for the right to egg back
right there base but there in actuality
those wonderful young people who are out
there making their mark have never said
that but but now suddenly that's the
debate but not the debate but one that
if the mirror image would be if a person
said when I'm elected
we are gonna repeal roe v wade yeah okay
that's the button pusher for the
Democrats that so it's the exact mirror
except to say that no but no she didn't
but there are people in the March by the
way the majority of people in the March
were adults and a lot of them were
talking about repealing the second oh
I'd be in other words you're looking at
someone who does not like yes the
availability of guns in society but
let's not put my opinion on what the
young people did they wrote it up it's
available e what you're describing is
exactly what somebody like Claire
McCaskill is saying which is that
Hillary Clinton doesn't speak for me and
what they're saying is they're not
asking her to shut up forever they're
just saying that we want to keep the
seats that we have well in certain
places like you can't give a speech now
without it being an international like
Surratt shirt brown in Ohio said much
the same thing one last point on this
which is that she was talking about
sexism and I was reminded as I was
reading her speech when she talked about
how Republicans oh she were so shrill
she's so shrill I can't stand her voice
I remember that it's awful and then you
know what you say but we need Hillary on
the right because we need someone to
demonize so that Donald Trump looks
somewhat like normal but guess what it
doesn't matter if any other woman had
been that candidate they would have been
vilified to pocahontas Pelosi look for
that scum novalog wonders Rogers twice
as many men that were
five bikes romp they were white they
were black
there were women about their worst Ryan
Ted yeah little Marco we got a run